[موسيقى]
حرب بالبيض الفاسد عراق بالايدي احتفالات
بالقاء النقود واخرى بتناول المخللات
والنقانق هكذا ودع العالم عام 2022
تعلم معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده
والغناء والرقص ربما هي الطقوس المعتده
والمشهوره لتوديع عام مضى واستقبال عام
جديد لكن هناك طقوس غريبه لدى بعض سكان
دول العالم للاحتفال بهذا الحدث في
اسبانيا مثلا وتحديدا في بلده ايبي يتم
تنظيم مهرجان
ديسمبر منذ 200 عامه المشاركون فيه
يتقذفون البيض الفاسد والدقيقه منتهي
الصلاحيه وسط الالعاب الناريه من تقليد
يمثل انقلابا وهميا من المعارضه ضد
السلطات الحاكمه
ماما
ومن اسبانيا الى اليابان حيث توافد الالاف
على ضريح نيجي المقدس وفقا للثقافه
المحليه هذه الطقوس تسمى هاتسو مود
وتتمثلوا في الصلاه والدعاء والقاء النقود
داخل الضريح طلبا للحظ السعيدي والتربه في
السنه الجديده اما في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف فقد حضر الالاف هنا وسط اجواء الحرب
لتناول الاطنان من سلطه المخللات والنقانق
للاحتفال بالعام الجديد
بس اوريكم كثير
اصلا
بورنو بورنو
[موسيقى]
يحتفلون باستقبال العام الجديد برقصه الدب
والماعز
المشاركوندو الملابس تقليديه ورقصوا
وتناول الطعام لابعاد الارواح الشريره عن
عائلاتهم في العام الجديد
منورين الدنيا
من الديانه الشماليه لاداء طقوس الدينيه
بالرقص والغناء وحرف البخور والتنبؤ
بالاحداث الكبرى التي ستحصل في العام 2013
امريكا
ليس هذا هو الطقس الوحيد لاستقبال العام
الجديد في بيروت فهنا مهرجان غريب يتمثل
في العراق والشجار يسمى تكناكويه
المشاركون فيه يخوضون عراكا بهدف تصفيه
الحسابات القديمه بينهم وبدء العام الجديد
من دون مشاحنات اما في كوستاريكا فيحتفل
سكان بنهايه العام بخوض المصارعه مع ثيران
لحضور الجماهير لكن هنا لا يتم اللمس
الحيوانات المشاركه في الاحتفال
شاركونا ارائكم اي الاحتفالات السابقه
ترغبون في المشاركه بها
[موسيقى]